якщо порівнюємо успіхи ну неможливо
порівнювати ту агресію яка відбулася в
14му15му році з дебальц наприклад з
ловайськом та іншим і порівнювати те що
відбулося 24го ми маючи агресію реальну
повномасштабну агресію з півноч і східну
від Російської імперії були набагато
успішні ж дебальцловайського дійсно
порівнювати неможливо і
це панеле що ви зараз роби чим міряєся
зараз відносно ми не мірся російсько
катлами російської армії вам зараз
Маріуполі ч нагадати ви що робите Не
треба зараз розказувати про дебальцева з
якого вийшли всі які були в оточенні а з
Маріуполя не вийшло 87 000 не треба цим
мірятися розумієте